programming to take you to the white
house where the u.s president joe biden
is making an address on energy prices
let's listen in
we uh we're responding
we're
aiding the ukrainian people both
economically militarily while leaving
the most punishing economic sanctions
against russia ever used against another
nation in place and increasing them
thus far
these actions are crippling russia's
economy
isolating putin from the world and
helping ukrainians fight for their
country
and ease their suffering
but as i've said from the start
putin's war is imposing the cost on
america and our allies and democracies
around the world
today
i want to talk about one aspect of
putin's war
that affects and has real effects on the
american people
putin's price hike that americans and
our allies are feeling at the pump
i know how much it hurts as you've heard
me say before i grew up in a family like
many of you
where the price of a gallon of gasoline
went up was discussions at the kitchen
table
our family budgets your family budgets
to fill a tank none of it should hinge
on whether a dictator declares war
so today i'm laying out a two-part plan
not only to ease the pain that families
are feeling right now but to end this
era of dependence and uncertainty
and to lay a new foundation for true and
lasting american energy independence
parenthetically just imagine if in fact
europe didn't have to count on russian
oil
if they were energy independent it would
change the nature of so much
the problem we're facing with gas prices
has two roots
first the pandemic
when cobot struck demand for oil
plummeted
so production slowed down worldwide
it's because of the strength and the
speed of our recovery demand for oil
shot back up much faster than the supply
that's why the cost of gas began to rise
last year
the second route is vladimir putin
the start of this year gas was about
three dollars and 30 cents a gallon
today it's about averaging 420 422 it's
higher in many states
nearly a dollar more in less than three
months
the reason for that is because of
putin's war
and now many people are no longer buying
russian oil around the world i banned
the russian import of oil here in
america republicans and democrats in
congress call for it and supported it
was the right thing to do
but i said at the time it's going to
come with a cost
as russian oil comes off the global
market
supply of oil drops and prices are
rising
now putin's price right
price hike is hitting americans at the
pump
which uh which brings me to the first
part of my plan
to immediately increase the supply of
oil
our prices are rising because of putin's
action there isn't enough supply
and the bottom line is if we want lower
gas prices we need to have
more oil supply right now
for u.s oil companies that are recording
their largest profits in years
they have a choice
one
they can put those profits to productive
use by producing more oils restarting
idle wells or producing on the sites
they already are leasing
giving the american people a break by
passing some of the savings on to their
customers and lowering the price of the
pump
or
they can as some of them are doing
exploit the situation sit back
ship those profits to the investors and
while american families struggle to make
ends meet
look this is a moment of consequence and
peril for the world
and pain at the pump for american
families
it's also a moment of patriotism
i want to acknowledge those companies
that have already announced their
increasing immediate production they're
investing money to produce more oil
and also clean technology we need to
reduce our dependence on oil in the
future
they have everything they need
nothing standing in their way
and they've indicated they will be
producing an extra 1 million barrels of
oil per day
probably starting as early as this fall
that's progress
but some companies have been pretty
blunt
they don't want to increase supply
because putin's price hike means higher
profits
one ceo even acknowledged that they
don't care if the price of a barrel of
oil goes to 200 a barrel
they're not going to step up the
production
i say enough
enough of lavishing excessive
profits on investors and payouts and
buybacks when the american people are
watching the world is watching
u.s oil companies made nearly 80 billion
dollars in profit last year initially
those profits are expected to continue
to soar
this is the time
not the time to sit on record profits
it's time to step up for the good of
your country to go to the world to
invest in immediate production that we
need to respond to vladimir putin
provide some relief for your customers
not investors and executives
look i'm a capitalist i have no problem
with corporations turning into good
profit but companies have an obligation
that goes beyond just their shareholders
to their customers their communities and
their country
no american company should take
advantage of a pandemic or vladimir
putin's actions to enrich themselves at
the expense of american families
investing those profits profits in
production and innovation that's what
they should do invest in your customers
and it isn't just like it's not the
patriotic view it's good for your
business as well
right now oil and gas industries sitting
on nearly 9 000 unused but approved
permits for production on federal lands
are more than a million unused acres
they have a right to to pump on
families can't afford that company sit
on these other hands
so
to help execute this first part of my
plan i'm calling for a use it or lose it
policy
congress should make companies pay fees
on wells on federal leases they haven't
used in years
and acres of public land they're
hoarding without production
companies that are already producing
from these wells won't be affected but
those sitting on unused leases and idle
wells will either have to start
producing or pay the price for their
inaction
look
the action i'm calling for will make a
real difference over time
but the truth is
it takes months not days for companies
to increase production
that's why the next part of my plan is
so important
today i'm authorizing the release of one
million barrels per day
for the next six months over 180 million
barrels
for the strategic from the
from the strategic petroleum reserve
this is a wartime bridge to increase oil
supply until production ramps up later
this year
and it is by far the largest release of
our net our national reserve in our
history
it'll provide historic amount of supply
for a historic amount of time a six
months bridge to the fall
and we'll use the revenue
from selling the oil now to restock the
strategic petroleum reserve when prices
are lower
so
we'll be ready we'll be ready for future
emergencies
folks
i've coordinated this release with
allies and partners around the world
already i've committed we have
commitments from other countries release
tens of millions of additional barrels
into the market
together our combined efforts that will
supply well over a million barrels a day
nations coming together to deny putin
the ability to weaponize his energy
resources against american families and
families and democracies around the
world
now
for the first part of my plan is about
meeting an immediate crisis the second
part
is about declaring real american energy
independence in the long term
so that we never have to deal with this
problem again
ultimately
we in the whole world need to reduce our
dependence on fossil fuels altogether
we need to choose long-term security
over energy and climate vulnerability
we need to double down on our commitment
to clean energy and tackling the climate
crisis with our partners and allies
around the world
and we can do that
by passing my plan that's literally
before the senate right now the united
states congress right now has been there
for well over a month
to speed the transition to clean energy
future
that's made in america with american
products and american values
we need to embrace all the tools and
technologies that can help us free us
from our dependence on fossil fuels
move us toward a more homegrown clean
energy
technologies made by american companies
and american workers so we can bolster
democratic supply excuse me domestic
supply chains here at home and export
those technologies around the world to
reduce greenhouse gases
that's why today i'm issuing a directive
to strengthen our clean energy economy
i'm going to use the defense production
act to secure american supply chains for
the critical materials that go into
batteries for electric vehicles and the
storage of renewable energy lithium
graphite nickel and so much more we need
to end our long-term reliance on china
and other countries for inputs that will
power the future
and i'll use every tool i have to make
that happen
yes
a building a made in america clean
energy future will help safeguard our
national security yes will help us
tackle climate change yes it's going to
help us ensure that america has created
millions of good paying jobs for
generations to come
but most important the most important
thing my plan will do right away is save
your family money here's what i mean
under my plan
which is before the congress now we can
take advantage of the next generation of
electric vehicles
that a typical driver will save about 80
a month from not having to pay gas at
the pump
if your home is powered by safer cheaper
cleaner electricity like solar or heat
pumps you can save about 500 a month on
average
don't take my word for it the ceos of 11
of america's largest
utility companies came to see me at the
white house several weeks ago
they told me if we pass my plans before
the congress now typical families will
see savings show up in their utility
bills immediately
costs will come down even more as we
innovate and develop cutting-edge energy
storage technologies clean hydrogens and
technologies advanced nuclear technology
carbon capture and sequestration
technologies
and by the way this week's
the benefit i included in the bipartisan
provide up to 6
500
direct payment for working class
families to be able to weatherize their
homes
save them money to keep them warm in the
winter and cool in the summer
it's a direct grant this program has
been brown for a while
and in the past it's delivered to
families average families another 327
dollars in savings when they weatherize
but now we have the ability to reach 10
times as many families because of the
legislation that we already passed in
the
in the legislation
in addition to that we're also setting
new standards to boost fuel economies
for new vehicles sold in america within
five years
we're going to travel 10 miles more on
every single gallon we have
because the average fuel economy
of 49 miles of the gallon is going to be
required
that means hundreds of dollars in
savings for families at the pump we're
also setting similar standards for
appliances from your air conditioner to
your microwave your refrigerator washers
dryers
it's just one of a hundred actions we're
taking to save the average family 100
per year in utility bills
look the bottom line is this
between wrapping up ramping up
production
in the short term and driving down
demand in the long term we can free
ourselves from our dependence on
imported oil from across the world
look i know gas prices are painful i get
it
my plan is going to help ease that pain
today
and safeguard again against tomorrow
i'm open to ideas to strengthen the plan
but i will not be put off and put it on
hold
it's time to deliver true long-term
energy independence in america once and
for all i'm going to continue to use
every tool at my disposal to protect you
from putin's price hike
it's not time for politics
america's americans can't afford that
right now
so let's meet this moment together
remember we're the only nation that has
turned every crisis we've ever faced in
an opportunity
we have a crisis priced at the pump so
let's show some true strength in this
nation show our unity our resolve our
innovative spirit in america
and come out of this long term much
better off
if we stand up to the bullies of the
world the autocrats and dictators we
stand up for those who are
are who are ready to unite unite with us
united states america
so may god bless you and may god protect
our troops thank you
vladimir putin being misinformed by his
advisors
that's an open question
uh there's a lot of speculation uh
but uh he seems to be i'm not saying
this with a certainty he seems to be
self-isolated
and there's some indication that he has
um
fired or put under house arrest some of
his advisors
um but i i don't want to put too much
stock in that at this time because we
don't have that much hard evidence
mr president how much in monetary terms
do you estimate today's announcement
will reduce gas prices and when can
americans expect to see these changes
that's a really important question and
there's no firm answer to it but prices
already came down when it was announced
ahead of time biden was going to release
so much and
so much energy from
so many barrels of oil from this probe
they're already come down my guess is
we'll see it come down continue to come
down
um but how far down i don't think anyone
can tell
and there's going to be a slight delay
because
if you go out there and you're a gas
station and you purchased x amount of
gas at a certain price
you're not going to lower the price of
the pump until you're able to get back
what you invested
and that i'm talking matter of i think
you know days and weeks
but it's hard to tell and the other
thing is exactly but it will come down
and it could come down fairly
significantly it could come down a
better part of you know anything from 10
cents to 35 cents a gallon it's unknown
at this point
i'm also waiting to see whether or not
our allies exactly how many
how many barrels
they release from their supplies now my
guess is it could be as high somewhere
between
30 million to 50 million barrels and the
higher the number the more likely the
prices to come out thank you all very
much i appreciate it thank you
this is al jazeera if you're joining us
this newshour we've just been listening
to the u.s president joe biden's remarks
on the rising oil prices biden announced
that he he spoke rather off quote the
pain at the pump and he did announce
millions of barrels of oil from reserves
to be released to try and lower soaring
crude prices over in the u.s biden says
that its historic use of u.s oil
stockpile will ease the pain for
americans let's get analysis with mike
hanna joining us from washington dc to
break down for us exactly what biden had
to say and what his plan is mike
well there's a lot to unpick here it's a
multi-pronged plan to ease the oil
crisis both domestically and globally in
the wake of the russian invasion of
ukraine first of all that release of a
million barrels a day from the strategic
petroleum fund for a maximum of six
months this is a massive amount of oil
that will go into the markets both
domestic and globally likely to increase
global oil reserves by some one percent
so this is a massive amount it's also
significant that this is being done says
the president in conjunction with the
us's allies so this is going to be done
by other western nations and other
nations who in terms of increasing the
global oil reserves which would perhaps
lower the oil price this is one part of
the biden plan the other part of the
biden plan is to make the us more energy
sufficient he says the nation has a
history of seizing opportunity in crisis
this is what he's attempting to do he
wants to now drive his clean energy plan
as a way of reducing oil prices he wants
to invoke the defense production act to
achieve this aim to be able to ease the
supply chains that have led to a
shortage of things like batteries which
have hindered uh the development of
electric cars for example but very
importantly too he launched a virtually
unprecedented attack on some oil
producers who he accused of seeking to
profit from the situation and to this
end he's proposing that congress enact
legislation that penalize oil producers
who have leased federal land or
areas of sea and are not producing on it
this is a virtually unprecedented action
and we've already heard from the speak
of the house that this is something that
the house will act on use it or lose it
is her call so a multi-pronged approach
from president biden with the aim he
says of reducing the prices at the pumps
for u.s citizens within the next weeks
it could appear he's pointed out that
oil prices have already dropped in the
news that there is going to be this
massive uh amount of strategic oil made
available but he says this is something
that is going to be short-term in terms
of the release of the extra petroleum
but also long-term is looking to
completely remake the u.s energy
industry that's a very ambitious
undertaking and we'll have more analysis
on this a little later in the newshour
for the time being mike hannah thank you
so much for that reporting from the
white house